you say because you weren't originally
from this I'm from Russia you say this
is one of the most tolerant countries
you know it is it is an even the
introduction that you gave where you
talked about the rise in a recorded hate
crime it's actually been debunked by the
Office of National Statistics who say
that hate crimes have dropped by 40% in
this country in the last 10 years
what we're seeing is we're taking the
issue of hate more seriously so the
police are getting better and better at
tracking and recording these crimes
another aspect of it actually is that if
you are rude to me on the course of this
program and I perceive that this is
motivated by my ethnicity or my
religious background and I report this
to the police the police are required to
record that as a hate incident without
investigating at all so we saw only a
few weeks ago somebody retweeting a
supposedly transphobic Limerick and that
being recorded as a hate incident not a
crime but as a hate incident and that
person getting a call from the police
and being told that they need to check
their thinking so what we're seeing I
think is a rightful focus on making sure
there's no hate in this in society but
this is Britain has never been more
tolerant and this is one of the most how
do you see that tolerance how does it
show itself in the British character or
not in some cases I think if people ask
themselves are we now a more tolerant
society than we were in the 70s and 80s
I think everyone will recognize well
that's happened and this you know as an
immigrant here I've been welcomed myself
you know I'm not oblivious to the fact
that some people are zena phobic and
some people are racist I've had people
tell me to go back to Pakistan and I'm
from Russia right and that's a reference
to my skin colour so I'm not oblivious
to that but what I think is it's
happened is we there's a narrative in
the media which is to talk about hate to
talk about all these issues and ignore
the facts yeah what do you think well
even the language that he uses is
problematic because